allein die vorstellung roko vier
alptraum noch können wir sie verhindern
das ist die gute nachricht ich behaupte
sogar da geht noch viel mehr als wir
denken zwischen fdp und grünen überlegen
sie mal beide sind gegen die
vorratsdatenspeicherung
für wahlrecht ab 16 und ganz wichtig
beide haben total reiche wähler
so viel gemeinsamkeit wäre doch kein
schlechtes paar ja und dann haben sie
diese woche auch noch gemeinsam die vor
sondierung erfunden hatten wir noch gar
nicht 48 stunden nach schließung der
wahllokale wurde schon vor sondiert und
111 ii sorgte für schnappatmung auf
sämtlichen kanälen alle welt spricht
über dieses foto 111 ii mit
seltenheitswert sell vom gestrigen abend
ist das wichtigste self wie deutschland
diese vier hier bei instagram auf
instagram selbst gemacht dass dann aber
doch jeder einen anderen licht filter
benutzt vielleicht ja ein hinweis auf
unterschiedliche ansichten bei mehreren
themen
ja oder ist einfach nur ein doofes elfi
und der filter hatten scheiß zu bedeuten
wenn natürlich hat herr lindner als
einziger den filter gefunden bei dem er
gut aussieht so klar wie war das
eigentlich so frage ich mich direkt
neben dem fotografiert zu werden
ja das dachte ich mir tatsächlich
erleben wir alle gerade live so was wie
eine revolution es gab es noch nie die
kleinen sind endlich mal am drücker und
und er wählen ihre großen partner fdp
und grüne ziehen sich zurück in ein grün
gelbes konklave und vor der tür hängt
ein schild alter mann zum mit koalieren
gesucht und jetzt könnten sich scholz
und laschet mit geschenken bei den neuen
machthabern bewerben scholz schenk
berbalk steuererhöhungen und ein pony
entschuldigung ein elektro pony tasche
zieht nach und schenkt lindner das ende
des soli und eine eisskulptur von
christian lindner und so geht das weiter
und am ende gucken sie dann gemeinsam
die neujahrsansprache von angela merkel
weil das alles so elendig lange dauert
ja noch nicht mal gucken vielleicht
überraschen sie uns man möchte so gerne
mäuschen spielen oder ich frage mich wer
geht da jetzt selbstbewusster in die
gespräche fdp oder doch die grünen eine
einerseits holen die grünen mit
14,8 prozent ihr bestes ergebnis
andererseits haben sie ihre zahlen aus
dem vorjahr halbiert
halbiert ist alles eine frage der
perspektive und erklärt möglicherweise
diese enthemmten szenen vom wahlamt
die grünen wollen sich dieses ergebnis
schön feiern will ich mal sagen können
dass hier mal angucken händler mir also
die party hat bereits begonnen die musik
würde aufgedrehten noch sind hier
auf der tanzfläche rauch das muss man
ganz klar sagen
junge er war ja bei uns in der
konfirmanden disco mehr stimmung grüne
und es ist übrigens völlig müßig zu
fragen ob man mit habeck vielleicht
erfolgreicher nicht grüne milieus
vorgestoßen wäre weiß keiner sicher ist
nur als die anna lena dem robert damals
die kanzlerkandidatur nahm als sie ihn
vielmehr genommen sein würde
das hat so doll weh getan ganz tief drin
dass bernburg ihm jetzt zur
wiedergutmachung die vizekanzler schafft
versprechen musste ich hatte eine
ambition und ich musste mich eine woche
lang schütteln um zu akzeptieren dass
ich diese ambition jetzt nicht leben
konnte
ambition hat sich auch mal war aber zum
glück gutartig jetzt darf also
vizekanzler werden das es gar nicht gibt
vizekanzler in der regierung von der
keiner weiß ob sie jemals kommt
glückwunsch robert ja und wenn sie
wissen wollen wie unfassbar unwichtig
dieses amt ist philipp rösler war mal
vizekanzler mehr muss man nicht wissen
ja echt blöd unglücklich dass diese vize
sache gelegt wurde denn man denkt ja
immer so bei den grünen unterstützen
da geht es immer um die sache die fahren
nicht so dass ego ding und wegen
tatsache ist zumindest bei den
sondierungsgesprächen ist habe ich jetzt
wohl das neue machtzentrum und er hat
sich einen ganzen sack voll neue
metaphern gekauft sondieren mit der fdp
das ist so es ist so als ob man sich in
einer partnerschaft aufzählt was man
doof findet aneinander geschweißt du
stellst die milchtüte mehr verkehrt im
kühlschrank lässt die socken herumliegen
und zu spät kommst du auch immer aber
jetzt ab nach mallorca und dann sagt man
so und die wollen wir uns jetzt
sozusagen eine wohnung gemeinsam teilen
und dann kommt da noch irgendwie eine
gelbe spachtelmasse dazu es geht darum
die schraube gerade rein zu setzen und
nicht von vornherein schräg 1 zu drehen
dann kann das kann der bibel niemals
halten ich habe jetzt ja nur spax
schrauben gedacht das ist ein dickes
brett da muss man irgendwie mit
verzierung reinbringen
das paar schrauben brauchen keine mutter
genau spax schrauben sind halbwaisen es
gibt so viele faszinierende fakten über
das dübeln ich könnte ihm stundenlang
zuhören aber wie kriegt man jetzt die
gelbe spachtelmasse namens fdp dazu auf
ihre steuersenkungen zu verzichten
wie wird nicht einfach prophezeit denn
die neue fdp kann vor kraft kaum laufen
warum weil die cats sie neuerdings leben
ja bei den erstwählern liegt die fdp
nach neuesten zahlen gleichauf mit den
grünen so ein hammer man denkt ja immer
nur an diese fridays kinder weil sie
ständig im fernsehen sind aber das
greift zu kurz junge menschen von heute
sind eben ganz anders als wir bei den
links grün verzichten medien uns das
wünschen sind eher so wie der junge
linda ran an die arbeit arbeit
bewältigen probleme sind eine dornier
chancen sagt der süße lindner prototyp
ja so ein würde ich noch mit 18 durch
die babyklappe stopfen zur wahrheit
gehört aber auch union und spd dürfen
sich gar nicht wundern dass ihnen die
vielen jungen wähler wegrennen schüler
und vor allem studenten wurden und
werden in der korona krise praktisch
ignoriert allein gelassen von der groko
die fdp spricht so was übrigens mal an
und gilt außerdem als coole digital
partei zu machen die kinder von heute ja
gar nicht mehr wissen wie analoge fdp
politiker früher geredet haben menschen
die hart arbeiten gehen darf man nicht
die butter vom brot nehmen
die homies das war der rainer brüderle
der hat in der politik damals viel käse
erzählt aber heute ist das eigentlich
auch wurst übrigens auch die moderne fdp
steht immer noch für längst widerlegten
quark wie trickle down also die
wissenschaft wenig schirmen und
besserverdiener entlaste haben am ende
irgendwie alle was davon leider nein
leider gar nicht weiß man heute die wahl
sensation
2021 immer mehr liberale erstwähler
schauen wir nicht länger weg die clean
los eine scheinbar normale familie doch
das verhalten von sohn konstantin gibt
den eltern allerdings anders zu sowie
heißen dax -2 prozent
die märkte haben angst vor steinen zu
sagt mal ließ er etwa den
wirtschaftsteil
der constantin der war eigentlich ein
ganz normaler gesunder junge stinkfaul
antriebslos hat viele pornos geguckt und
jetzt erweist sich plötzlich macht seine
hausaufgaben muss die nachbarn unter da
kam uns halt dieser verdacht
wird unser sohn vielleicht die fdp
ist
leider kein einzelfall immer mehr junge
deutsche driften ab in die welt des
liberalismus die ersten anzeichen werden
oft übersehen zb das lachsfarbene polo
rennt
besonders mit aufgestelltem kragen
[Musik]
und dann kommt unweigerlich der eine
moment in dem es keine zweifel mehr gibt
[Musik]
natürlich machst du dir da vorwürfe
als vater fragst du dich auf wasser da
versagt
fdp wählen ist ja auch immer hilfe
tatsächlich ist liebe die einzige
antwort auf junge fdp-wähler geduld mit
einem menschen den man fast nicht mehr
wiedererkennt
taxi zur schule macht jetzt in brüssel
war so viel arme leute ist zwar teuer
aber du weißt ja papa probleme sind auch
nur dornige chancen
alles klar verstehe
bei allem schmerz eltern sollten nie
vergessen mit etwas glück ist fdp wählen
im leben ihres kindes nur eine kurze
phase
constantin was sind jetzt los ich bin
niemandem moral in der satan ist sondern
auch
klasse
sie ist alles wird gut
naja mal abwarten ob wirklich alles gut
wird die liberale rasselbande träumt
nämlich von der jamaika koalition und
auch einige grüne von jamaica verlocken
weil sie von einer verzweifelten union
vielleicht mehr zugeständnisse kriegen
fakt ist aber und darüber denkt bitte
mal nach grüne deutschland steht vor
gigantischen herausforderungen und die
worte laschet und neu anfangen können
gar nicht im selben satz vorkommen
außerdem laut dieser umfrage ist jamaika
mit 19 prozent noch unbeliebter eine
bevölkerung als figur co kurz gesagt
grüne tut das nicht
die heute show sagt lotze jamaika
unserer aktion liga über der grünen
zentrale kreisen 24 stunden am tag
flugzeuge mit monika bannern dem lindner
sinsen wir einmal stündlich das fdp
wahlergebnis nach seiner letzten
regierung mit der union und jedes mal
wenn ihr euch irgendwo trifft beschallen
wir euch von draußen gnadenlos mit der
hymne unserer bewegung
mai kann
mein reden nur aika weniger cry
knisternde spannung im politischen
berlin wo treffen sich grüne und fdp zum
nächsten self und noch wichtiger wer
benutzt diesmal welchem foto filter am
dienstag haben sie alle überrascht mit
ihrem geheimtreffen das darf uns nicht
noch mal passieren wir schalten live in
die hauptstadt zu tina hausten sie
beobachtet für uns die relevanten
szenelokale china wie ist die lage in
berlin über die lage ist ehrlich gesagt
verwirrend je länger man über das elfi
vom dienstag nachdenkt umso mehr neue
rätsel tun sich auf so viele versteckte
hinweise zum beispiel warum hat nur
robert habeck das bild im querformat
gepostet zufall oder ist er vielleicht
doch querdenker ohne frage und noch
verwirrender warum zum teufel sieht man
christian lindner hier plötzlich in
farbe
wussten sie dass es den mann im bund
gibt wegen der coolen plakate dachte man
natürlich die lindner ist schwarz weiß
wen kann man noch glauben ja wo genau
sind sie da jetzt gerade vom borchardt
wo der fdp zentrale
nein wie denn das hier ist berlin
ich versuche seit fünf tagen zu wählen
aber mein wahllokal hat immer noch keine
neuen stimmzettel wenn ich jetzt zur fdp
verliere ich habe meinen platz in der
schlange ihr in westdeutschland mögen
das vielleicht spannend finden wer
demnächst im bund regiert aber hier in
venezuela an der spree haben wir ganz
andere sorgen im bezirk
charlottenburg-wilmersdorf haben 22
bezirke ein identisches wahlergebnis die
erklärung hier wurde einfach geschätzt
um erst mal überhaupt ein ergebnis zu
haben chaos vor den wahllokalen lange
warteschlangen fehlende unterlagen und
genervte berliner dann kamen sie heraus
haben gesagt dass es
gibt einfach keine zettel mehr oder
wohin mir gesagt ich könnte nur hause
gehen ich sagen kann der wahlzettel
ulkig genau mit dem trick hat honecker
auch immer seine wahlen gewonnen sorry
genossen leider keine zettel mehr da
ich sage ihnen was oliver wenn wir pech
haben muss wegen berlin die ganze
bundestagswahl wiederholt werden geklagt
hat anscheinend auch schon einer ein
gewisser armin l aus aachen um sie
konnte sekunde ich glaube davon bewegt
sich was
tiger in mehreren berliner bezirken gab
es am ende wohl mehr stimmen als
wahlberechtigte wie kann sowas passieren
weil wir uns übernommen haben wahl und
berlin marathon am selben tag wie soll
das gehen das sind ja gleich zwei dinge
auf einmal das geht nun wirklich nicht
und übrigens der marathon ist natürlich
auch noch nicht vorbei
der welt lacht über dieser stadt
franziska giffey hat berlin gerade eine
zukunftsfähige welt stadt genannt
wir können mich mal zettel in wahllokale
bringen aber gut so langsam geht's ja
wieder bergauf berlin nach der panne nur
als das chaos geht weiter einige bürger
haben geschlossen weil die mitarbeiter
als wahlhelfer eingesetzt waren und sich
erst einmal erholen müssen ja klar da
bist du natürlich fix und fertig ja
sitzt den ganzen tag da ohne zettel
alles wird gut ich höre gerade berlin
ist gerettet wegen des wahlkampfs am
sonntag kommen jetzt die alliierten
zurück
schokolade
china aus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
tina hausten live aus deutschlands
beliebtestem failed state in dem alten
schlager ich hab noch einen koffer
voller wahlzettel in berlin die
landeswahlleiterin ist inzwischen
übrigens zurückgetreten ich würde sagen
konsequent am ende einer woche die viele
verlierer gesehen hat manche tun einem
leid andere so gar nicht meinte auch
dietmar wischmeyer in einer neuen folge
von
[Musik]
menschen im abseits dietmar wischmeyer
klagt an heute wahl verliert
schon wieder ist ein kanzlerkandidat aus
der region aachen gescheitert armin
laschet sitzt bereits ganz vorne im
schulz zug nach nirgendwo aber das ist
ja nicht der einzige geplatzte traum vom
letzten wochenende
ich sag nur hubert aiwanger der
posterboy der ungeimpften hat es mit
seinen freien wählern leider nicht in
den bundestag geschafft also er bleibt
natürlich bayerischer vizekönig und
macht markus söder weiter das leben zur
hölle zum beispiel indem er am
wahlsonntag einfach schon mal die
geheime prognose twittert er ist heute
äußerte sich der freie-wähler-chef zur
vorzeitigen veröffentlichung der noch
geheimen prognose dies war in
missgeschick die details werden wir
klären das kommt schon mal vor er zahlt
beim schaufeln mit der mistgabel an der
computermaus hängengeblieben passiert
blöd ließ auch für die kleinste brille
der welt für hans-georg maßen mister bin
nicht in die cdu eingetreten mit 1,8
millionen araber nach deutschland kommen
jetzt hat sich rausgestellt die araber
haben es zwar nach deutschland geschafft
aber eher nicht in den bundestag hier
stimme der basis im moment das ist doch
das ist doch
recht weisen
also ich wäre so manche ideen sie nicht
schlecht man denn kurz er hat ein
problem damit dass maßen ein rechter ist
andererseits wo sie den ossi an sich mal
in schutz nehmen beim blick auf die afg
direktmandate wir haben nämlich gar kein
ost problem wir haben höchstens ein
problemchen im neuen bau deutsch südost
sonst nix bis frage wer sieht zwar aus
wie ein rentner muss jetzt aber trotzdem
weiter arbeiten
gut war zu einfach philipp am tor hat es
über die landesliste in meck-pomm es
gerade so geschafft aber ohne
direktmandat peinlich was ist denn hier
los hat der wähler etwa plötzlich was
gegen korruption seien wir doch dankbar
dass es noch leistungsbereite junge
menschen gibt die ihre socken selber
bügeln und sich für deutsche werte
interessieren ich bin ja echt fan von
bier und bratwurst auch mal dunkel so
lade für e.on war was rustikales
schnitzel und spargel durchaus er team
popcorn und natürlich sehr gerne
wildfleisch bratkartoffeln salami und
ein bisschen schinken aber auch für
nachos zu haben backbone mit brutal ich
würde sagen eine meiner lieblings
wozzeck gruppen ist die whatsapp gruppe
würstchen gulasch übrigens selbst da ist
er rausgeflogen also keine direktmandate
für amt maßen und aiwanger der deutsche
wähler ist eben doch viel schlauer als
man denkt bitte sehr wer hat ein
direktmandat geholt
doch ein
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
eine last
ich hab die schnauze voll
auslasten abo da